welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we're taking your calls at eight
five five two thirty six thirty two
twenty eight that's eight five five two
three six thirty two twenty eight Joel
in Kansas City Missouri Joel you're on
the bench oh go for it hey Ben as
someone that often finds the Libertarian
candidate better in their positions over
Republican candidate I've often wanted
to vote for the libertarian in a general
election and solve that I believe
rank-choice voting would helps that I
wanted to know your opinion on a wrench
choice voting if that's something that
you see helpful in a general or primary
election so I kind of like the idea of
ranked choice voting now the Iowa
caucuses are horrible example of ranked
choice voting caucus is basically
because you are in a group of people who
don't understand how ranked choice
voting works and so they will go over to
the Andrew yang crowd then when it
doesn't hit the threshold then you have
to redistribute them among the other
voters that is rank choice voting but
nobody in the room actually knows how
that works if you actually had people
write it down on a ballot what the
ranked choices were and not pressure
each other as though they were at some
sort of middle-eastern bazaar then that
would that would be a better way to do
it ranked choice voting for folks who
don't understand is let's say that you
were let's use the Iowa caucuses as an
example let's say you wanted vote for
Andrew Yang but Andrew yang isn't gonna
win so you have to a certain threshold
let's say ten percent okay so you vote
for Andrew yang and then you write down
as my second choice I want Joe Biden and
so Andrew yang loses he gets below ten
percent and now your second choice vote
instead of your vote being completely
thrown out and you being useless now
your second choice vote goes to Joe
Biden who's actually competitive what
that would do in terms of national
elections would mean that let's say that
you voted for gary johnson last time and
your second choice vote was donald trump
right your last choice vote was hillary
clinton so you write down gary johnson
and then your second choice vote would
be donald trump what that means as more
people would vote for gary johnson
because they know their votes not gonna
get thrown out if they vote for gary
johnson gary johnson would get 12% of
the vote 13% of the vote and then in the
second round three-quarters of those
votes get kicked over to trump and Trump
wins those votes as opposed to these
sort of weird election results where you
have like in 1992 Ross Perot winning 18%
of the vote and Bill Clinton winning
with 42% of the vote I'm not against
rank-choice voting I think it's a clever
idea and
I agree with you that it would actually
emboldened people to vote for third
parties more often which frankly I think
would be a good thing more choices are
better in American politics and the
two-party system has basically resulted
in a long-standing agreement that nobody
will ever take tough positions about
anything related to spending or anything
politically unpalatable Joel so I'm sort
of with you I kind of like running tries
voting all right thanks man I really
appreciate the call Marion New Jersey
are on the bench Pierre I'll go for it
Mary hey Ben first of all you Tran
what are you convict in the New York New
Jersey area I believe we are doing a
speech I don't want to announce which
University is we're doing a speech on
the East Coast with young America's
Foundation I believe in April so we will
try the public eye well I think one of
the conditions is that we only do
speeches they're only open to the public
I hope I mean that obviously is what I
would prefer fantastic I would love to
see you there my question is tonight we
are in for the State of the Union but
we've had quite a few dramatic months
between January and the first week of
February do you think Trump is going to
use that as his platform to ramble off
or is he gonna actually take this as
chance to bring for his images for
novaro 2020 well I think that he will be
pretty disciplined in the State of the
Union addresses before he typically has
been he really has stuck to the
teleprompter now so I think that he will
wink and nod at certain points
absolutely I do not think that Trump is
capable of going a full hour long speech
without making some snide backwards
reference to impeachment for example I
don't think he's gonna mention Iowa per
se but I wouldn't be surprised if he
throws in some sort of oblique reference
that everybody gets but he doesn't say
it quite overtly correct I mean it's
just I feel like he would go out and we
love Trump but at the same time he's
does walk in mouth off so is there a
chance well Walker's Naza and win 2020
the election for him well I mean I don't
think he'll do that in the State of the
Union address but there's always the
opportunity for him to do that there's a
long time between now and November
Trump's worst enemy in this election is
not gonna be the Democrat it's gonna be
Donald Trump really appreciate the call
Marriott if we can squeeze in one more
phone call see fuller in Arkansas you're
on the bench Bureau show cohort foler
I've been good morning so I think it's
pretty well known that college campuses
are overtly biased even in a very deep
red state like Arkansas
I'm a senior in college and we see
plenty of bye
on our campuses I know you go around and
we address it but without violating our
own beliefs of government involvement
how do we protect conservative students
and force a change without like I said
getting the government involved
well fuller it's a great question I
honestly I think the only way this is
gonna change is when the market changes
and that's why we a daily wire do not
screen job candidates by college degree
instead we bring people in for
interviews we look at their job
characteristics we don't as long as it
is more beneficial to get a degree from
a liberal arts college that hates
conservatives than it is to just go
straight into the workforce there's
gonna be a problem and I think that
employers particularly conservative
employers need to rethink what college
means and act accordingly already coming
up we'll bring you the latest from Iowa
Democrats are going to release half the
results half I'm not kidding is the ben
shapiro show